twitter has revealed new details about
one of the biggest cyber attacks on the
social network
it believes hackers accessed its
internal systems
after targeting twitter employees
yesterday fake messages appeared on the
twitter accounts of dozens of
celebrities
politicians and billionaires including
barack obama
elon musk and kanye west twitter ceo
jack dorsey wrote
tough day for us at twitter we all feel
terrible this happened
we're diagnosing and we'll share
everything we can
when we have a more complete
understanding of exactly what happened
anna werner shows us how the scam worked
the tweet from tesla and spacex founder
elon musk seemed too good to be true
i'm feeling generous because of covid19
i'll double any btc
payment sent to my btc address for the
next hour
good luck and stay safe out there the
address to send the cryptocurrency
posted right below similar tweets
appeared on the accounts of celebrities
kanye west and kim kardashian west
politicians former president obama and
joe biden
and billionaires michael bloomberg jeff
bezos and bill gates
companies like apple and uber were also
targeted
here's how it worked the sophisticated
scammers took over verified accounts
then convinced twitter users following
those accounts to send bitcoin
a digital currency that can be traded
for dollars to a website
and promised double the money back
within hours twitter limited functions
for all verified accounts and
acknowledged the hack
saying we are investigating and taking
steps to fix it
it's a terrifying moment for twitter
nick thompson is wired's editor-in-chief
and says the way the scam was executed
hacking into twitter itself and not
individual accounts
makes it stand out from others normally
when you see the scam it's coming from
the address of someone whose name you
don't know
it's not coming from elon musk thompson
says hijacking verified accounts in an
age when tweets make news
could have disastrous consequences now
that so much of life happens on twitter
getting access to the most popular
verified accounts
and you can do near infinite damage
twitter's still investigating this hack
the big question of course
who was the hacker nobody knows that
right now
but the company says it had locked most
compromised accounts
and would reopen them when it was safe
to do so
tony yeah the big question is who was
the hacker also what else may they
have in the direct messages for example
in those twitter accounts anna thank you
very much